hey guys welcome to this video on
digital marketing career
jobs resume salary skills roles and
responsibilities
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for
from technology to healthcare our lives
have greatly improved for the better
and many of these things wouldn't have
been possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved our lives
the internet has also made the life of
marketers a whole lot easier earlier
unless you had lots of money or were
very popular
your brand's popularity would be limited
to your locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to
anyone anywhere in the world the whole
world is now
your marketplace and that is because of
digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
goods services
and your brand with the help of digital
channels like
websites social media platforms search
engines
and so on digital marketing has the
following types
search engine optimization content
marketing
social media marketing search engine
marketing
affiliate marketing native advertising
marketing automation and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are
incorporated into a brand's marketing
campaigns
to ensure the best possible output
a digital marketer of course so now
let's talk about everything related to a
digital marketer
but before we can get started let's go
to a more familiar setting
on where a digital marketer belongs and
strives
the office now let's start by talking
about
who is a digital marketer a digital
marketer
is someone whose objective is use
digital channels
like search engines social media
platforms
affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads
and build brand awareness everything the
digital marketer is aimed at
helping the brand grow but that's not
where his or her responsibilities end
a digital marketer is also responsible
for
developing and managing marketing
campaigns
this means that the success of the
entire marketing efforts of a brand
or an organization entirely depends on
how competently
a digital marketer develops the
marketing campaign
the work doesn't end there though the
digital marketer
also needs to manage the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads
and drive traffic to the brand's website
taking advantage of the digital channels
we mentioned earlier
alongside providing high quality content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis
and industry benchmarking to understand
what kind of content works best within
your industry
the kind of content that your
competition posts
and what works for them they're also
responsible for using
tools like buffer hootsuite and sprout
social
to measure and optimize marketing
campaigns
based on data obtained from the tools
and finally they're responsible for
improving brand awareness
by advertising the organizations or
brands content on digital marketing
channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing
there's search engine optimization
content marketing
social media marketing search engine
optimization
affiliate marketing and email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with seo you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services
that your brand is offering without
having to pay a single penny
the process of seo has two parts
on page and off page seo let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on page seo
on on-page or on-site seo is a method of
search engine optimization
that involves the optimization of
elements on a website
like its content or html code to help
increase the amount of traffic coming to
your website and
improve its search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is
all about and whether or not your page
addresses their search query
on-page seo is possible with the help of
keyword
research technical audits on-site
optimizations
and enhanced user experiences
next we have off-page seo off-page
or off-site seo refers to actions
taken outside your website to affect
your rankings
in search engine result pages it
involves promotional methods to improve
search engine
and user perception of your site's
popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
off-page seo can also be performed with
the help of link building
which is getting other websites to link
back to your website
some of the popular seo tools are moz
google keyword planner semrush and
ahrefs next up
we have content marketing content
marketing refers to the process of
marketing
that focuses on creating and sharing
valuable
relevant and consistent content like
blogs
videos infographics and case studies to
bring the attention of a targeted online
audience
to the brand's products and services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign
do you want more subscribers more
conversions
increased leads that's what you need to
decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas
a buyer persona is a profile created
based on
research that represents the target
customer
that might enjoy your products or
services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a content
audit
it involves taking a look at all the
content on your website
and assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a content
management system of your choosing
there are a number of options available
like wordpress mailchimp and squarespace
you will need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content
that will attract the attention of new
audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on
and finally you will need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools
there's buffer basumo follower wonk
and hootsuite let's now talk about
the next type of digital marketing that
is social media marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms
to connect with your audience to build
your brand
to increase sales and to drive traffic
you will need to listen to and engage
with followers
analyze results and run social media
advertisements
the process of social media marketing
involves
like before you first need to determine
what goal you want to achieve
you need to determine whether you need
increased conversions
email sign ups lead generation or
any other marketing goal at this stage
you'll need to determine what your
audience enjoys the most
you need to find out which files get the
most amount of engagement
likes or shares then you'll need to
research about your competition
within your niche see what kinds of
content they post
what content of theirs receives the most
engagement from their audience
and how you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit
through which you can analyze content on
your social media profile
and understand their strengths and
weaknesses to determine what kinds of
content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice
like linkedin facebook instagram
twitter or youtube and start creating
marketing strategies
on how to make the most out of them you
should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post
and how you can replicate the same you
will then need to create a social media
calendar
these are spreadsheets or applications
that will enable you to plan your social
media posts
in advance you can plan when content
will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
and finally you will need to keep
testing evaluating
and making adjustments to your marketing
campaigns
to finally reach the sweet spot where
you have a perfect social media
marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools
there is hootsuite tweetdeck sprout
social
and buffer just to name a few next up
let's have a look at search engine
marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that
involves websites increasing the amount
of traffic
as well as their visibility on search
engine result pages
by taking advantage of paid advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve
with your sem campaign mode leads
conversions subscriptions you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight
as choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against
larger ones in a bidding battle you have
no chance of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise
and then start bidding on them to ensure
that a user sees your ad
when they search for that particular
keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns
as a well-written headline for your ad
can make the difference between a
potential customer coming to your
website
and buying your products and then being
completely turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure
how well you're doing so that you can
make the appropriate adjustments
and finally you will need to make sure
you make regular
optimizations and adjustments based on
the data you've collected and
retarget potential customers to renew
their interest in your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are google ads
facebook ads manager ad role
and binge ads just to name a few next up
let's take a look at affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an
affiliate who could be a particular
website or other entity
to advertise a merchant's products the
affiliate usually promotes the product
and earns a commission for each sale
they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations
email sign ups conversions and
subscriptions
here's the process of affiliate
marketing first
you will need to decide the affiliate
network you want to choose
the affiliate network is like a favor
for both merchants and affiliates here
a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with
and vice versa as a merchant
you will need to set up specific rules
guidelines
image specifications commission costs
and other details that an affiliate
needs to accept
before they can apply to advertise for
you
after this affiliates apply to advertise
on the merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with
and would be the best representation of
their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads
and are sent to the merchant's website
if customers make a purchase
the affiliate network makes a note of it
the transaction
is then validated and credited to the
affiliate
and finally the affiliate is given his
or her commission and likewise the
process repeats
itself here are some of the popular
affiliate marketing tools
we have cj affiliate volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing
and that is email marketing email
marketing is the process of using
personalized emails to convert
prospective users into potential
customers
here's the process of email marketing
first
you decide on what goal you want to
achieve with your email marketing
campaign
then you decide what kind of emails you
want to send
is it a welcome email a newsletter a
lead nurturing email
a re-engagement email that's what you've
got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing
these tools can help you with templates
for emails
create email lists track performance
and do much more you will then need to
attract users with a reason to subscribe
to your emails
with attractive opt-in advantages like
exclusive access to sales
discounts and so on you will need to
plan emails
and their respective follow-ups with an
email calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy
that will attract the attention of
potential customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy
your email also has to have an
attractive design
and finally you will need to perform a
or b
tests and use analytics to measure how
well your campaign is doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure
the upcoming campaigns are a success
some popular email marketing tools
are mailchimp hubspot sendinblue
and marketo just to name a few now
let's take a look at some digital
marketer carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have
we'll be talking about the salaries of
these job roles
courtesy of glassdoor first we have
digital marketing manager
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately
75 000 dollars per annum in the us
in india he or she can earn
approximately 7
lakh rupees per annum next we have
seo manager in the united states
an seo manager earns approximately 62
000 dollars per annum
whereas in india an seo manager earns
approximately
five lakhs per annum then we have search
engine marketing or ppc expert
a ppc expert in the us earns
approximately seventy four thousand
dollars per annum
whereas in india a ppc expert can earn
approximately four lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the us
a social media manager earns
approximately
fifty thousand dollars per annum in
india
he or she can earn approximately five
lakhs per annum
and finally we have the content
marketing manager
a content marketing manager can earn
approximately
65 000 dollars in the united states
in india he or she can earn
approximately
5 lakh rupees per annum let's have a
look at a sample digital marketer resume
first off you start off with the usuals
like name
address and the other stuff following
this
you will need to add a brief summary of
your years of experience
and the different important skills you
have experience with
in this case this person has two years
of experience
in just about every important type of
digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for
you give them links to your socials and
then add experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements
during your years of work here you can
see how this person has brought growth
in just about every channel he's gotten
into the most important part to remember
here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative
with actual stats about how your work
brought growth to your organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for
you can choose to elaborate on some of
your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with
make sure you add relevant tools related
to this job role you're looking for
for example for the role of a sem expert
having experience with google ads and
google analytics is mandatory
so that has to be a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education
and then talk about the courses you've
completed
having completed the right courses can
have a significant impact on your higher
ability
so how can simply learn help you
here's how here are
some of the advantages of taking simply
learns course
simply learns job assist access to more
than 45
projects access to tools worth more than
500 dollars
get omcp certified master concepts of
seo
email marketing mobile marketing ppc
web analytics social media marketing and
so much more and there you go we've
covered everything you need to know to
get started on your digital marketing
journey
if you enjoyed this video we would
greatly appreciate
a like and a share also don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell
icon as we have a lot more exciting
videos
coming your way thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more
from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here